[Musique]
c'est fou à quel point la peur en très
peu de temps peut donner des ailes à une
fausse rumeur
si jamais tu évolues merde entre cause
de l'auteur ou danton frischherz
éleveurs jacques boisseau pour l crise
grâce aux poubelles
ce que vous venez d'entendre et un
extrait d'un court message audio qui a
rapidement fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux les 3 et 4 avril dernier une
femme dont le frère a travaillerait dans
les installations trifluvienne de
l'entreprise bien connu olymel exhorte
les gens à jeter tous leurs produits
tous les produits olymel parce qu'ils
pourraient être infectés par le nouveau
coronavirus c'est faux et plusieurs
personnes sont tombées dans le piège
mon collègue nicolas de rosa à rectifier
les faits
d'abord l'agencé canadienne d'inspection
des aliments soutient que la coved 19 ne
se propage pas sur la nourriture et qui
n'existe actuellement aucune preuve
suggérant que l'alimentation est une
source où une voix probable de
transmission du virus
ensuite olymel n'a pas tardé à réagir
face à l'inquiétude suscitée par cette
rumeur non fondée
tout ça est absolument faux dit richard
vigneault le porte-parole de
l'entreprise
ainsi la comédie 19 se transmettait dans
l'alimentation elle se transmettrait
dans tous les produits
si c'était vrai pour nous ce serait vrai
pour tout le monde at il précisé on fera
travailler à l'iml trois regards
d'enfants et clément il me dit que ce
soit sauf que les chocs de cet esprit et
les chocs de ses cinq enfants y ont été
fermés parce qu'il y avait cinquante
neuf cas de qovu 19 encore une fois ce
que vous venez d'entendre est fausse et
extrait du même message audio les usines
de l'e-mail à saint-esprit et à
saint-hyacinthe sont encore bel et bien
ouverte c'est de cet esprit a par contre
récemment réduit ces abattages de 50%
pourquoi entre autres parce qu'elle ne
peut plus faire venir de manoeuvre de
montréal en raison de la copie 19 la
seule fermeture à signaler chez olymel
concerne l'usiné de yamachiche qui a
fermé temporairement en raison des
nombreux cas de kobe 19 parmi son
personnel
donc ne soyons pas trop vite sur la
gâchette assurons-nous qu'une
information est fondée avant de la
partager
vous avez des doutes fait nous saigner
l'équipe des décrypteurs est là
salut
[Musique]